MARTHA HUNT: So hi, guys.
I'm really excited
to be here today.
This is my first Google Talk.
And I'm very excited to
be talking about fashion
with my friend Jason Wu.
He's a very creative
and talented designer,
one of the best in the world.
So let's get started.
JASON WU: Sure.
MARTHA HUNT: We've known each
other for about five years now,
right?
JASON WU: Yeah.
It seems like forever ago.
MARTHA HUNT: I know.
It's crazy.
JASON WU: Next year is
my 10th anniversary, so--
MARTHA HUNT: And you
definitely didn't even
have three lines when I met you.
JASON WU: No.
MARTHA HUNT: So much
has changed since then.
JASON WU: Now I have
a thousand jobs.
It was a much more
innocent time.
MARTHA HUNT: So the most--
JASON WU: I love this camera.
I can see which
angle I look better.
This is better, less fat.
MARTHA HUNT: He's
not vain, I promise.
So the most recent
time that we hung out
was for the launch for
your "Grey" Jason Wu line.
That was a really fun dinner.
I had such a good time.
JASON WU: Cool.
MARTHA HUNT: Let's
talk first about how
you started your career in
fashion and what inspired you.
JASON WU: Yeah, I mean, I
started around 10 years ago
when I was 23.
And I left school, which
means I did not graduate.
That was a nice
way of saying it.
And I just really wanted to get
my hands dirty and really work.
I was always just been
really curious about how
everything worked.
I'm not the kind that likes to
read instruction manuals very
much.
I just want to do
things and try it out.
So that's kind of what I did.
I went into the industry.
I didn't even really
know that much.
I mean, I had interned
before, but I didn't really
know so much about the
ins and outs of fashion
and how complicated
everything was.
So it definitely was trial by
fire going into the industry.
But I would say
the one great thing
about it is that I
think I can say now
I've done every job that
exists in my company, which
is really nice because
to be able to really have
that understanding, even if
I'm not doing everything.
MARTHA HUNT: That's impressive.
You had to learn
everything on your own.
JASON WU: Yeah, I remember
carrying big paper patterns
down Seventh Avenue.
And then getting them graded.
And then we were like, oh.
In school, you only
have to make one sample.
And we're like,
oh, we didn't know
we have to do different
sizes, different things--
like all those things.
MARTHA HUNT: A big
learning curve.
JASON WU: Yeah, a big
learning curve, yeah.
MARTHA HUNT: Well,
it's really sounds
like the classic American
story-- immigrant family,
your family really
believed in you,
and you're really self-made,
which I think is amazing.
What have been some challenges
throughout the fashion industry
that you've encountered
throughout the way?
JASON WU: Well, I think,
in general, I definitely
don't come from a
background of fashion.
My dad is in the
agriculture industry.
So it's very, very far.
MARTHA HUNT: Very different.
JASON WU: Very different.
He specializes in animal feed.
So that's the whole opposite.
So everyone's like, is
your family in fashion?
I was like, really very,
very far from that.
MARTHA HUNT: He probably still
doesn't understand what you do.
JASON WU: No, not really.
No.
You walk into--
MARTHA HUNT: Just vogue.com.
JASON WU: You walk
into his office,
and there's a big marble
sculpture of a pig.
He's obsessed with pigs.
MARTHA HUNT: Wow.
JASON WU: Literally.
And the irony is I'm allergic
to pork, so very sad.
MARTHA HUNT: No bacon for you.
JASON WU: True story, though.
No, but I think, definitely,
some of the challenges are
I came up.
I didn't really know that much.
And I didn't have
a lot of money.
MARTHA HUNT: Wow.
JASON WU: So I started
using the seed money that I
got from working in toys.
When I was in high
school, I double-dutied
as a toy designer.
MARTHA HUNT: Oh, really?
JASON WU: Yeah, it's a whole--
MARTHA HUNT: Like
what kind of toys?
JASON WU: Dolls.
MARTHA HUNT: Oh.
JASON WU: I used to play with
dolls when I was growing up.
MARTHA HUNT: Ah, that doesn't
surprise me for some reason.
JASON WU: I know.
And so that was how
it all happened.
But I would say I was way
more adventurous back then
than I am now.
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah,
had to conform.
JASON WU: A little bit.
MARTHA HUNT: So let's talk
about technology and fashion,
and how that's changed the
industry perspective for you.
I'm sure you have to incorporate
a lot of social media
and technology
with your business.
JASON WU: Yeah, I mean, I
think it's all changing.
I think one of the things that
may seem like the tech world
and what I do is very far apart.
But, in fact, so much
of what we do now
is reliant on technology,
like the way we weave fabric,
the way we work with synthetics.
When fabric used to be woven,
they were all done by hand.
So you think how
many fibers goes
into the little thread that goes
into the making of a fabric.
MARTHA HUNT: Wow.
JASON WU: That was all
done by hand before,
so obviously the
productivity level,
and also the ability to do
things on a more advanced way
is interesting.
Like the garment
you're wearing today
from my collection "Grey,"
it's all laser-cut.
There's no traditional
hand-finishing on any of it.
Super light, it doesn't
wrinkle so much.
It's all just like
synthetics that we're
able to play with nowadays, play
with different modern finishes.
And that's what technology
has done for us.
As an industry, we can
get more innovative
in terms of on how
we make clothes.
Less literal like light-up
clothes, but more like,
how do you make clothes lighter?
How do you make them in
a more efficient way?
And how do you--
MARTHA HUNT: Quicker
and more efficient.
JASON WU: Quicker and more
efficient, but also just more
precise.
MARTHA HUNT: Well, what
about social media?
JASON WU: Yeah,
I mean, it's fun.
I mean, I just recently
took up Snapchat.
MARTHA HUNT: You got to do it.
All the kids are Snapchatting.
JASON WU: Follow me @jasonwu.
She's very good.
I'm still learning.
MARTHA HUNT: Oh, yeah?
JASON WU: Yeah, I Snapchat
a bunch last night,
but I was drunk.
And I woke.
I was doing a "W
Magazine" takeover.
And I was like,
shit, this morning?
I was like, whoa.
And all that.
MARTHA HUNT: No, those
make the best Snapchats.
JASON WU: I know.
They're kind of funny.
MARTHA HUNT: It
shows the real you.
The fun Jason.
JASON WU: I know.
Because everyone always
think I'm very serious.
MARTHA HUNT: Oh, he's not
serious, not serious at all.
JASON WU: Well,
that's why I wanted
to just talk with you because
we're actually friends.
MARTHA HUNT: Yes.
JASON WU: So it
doesn't feel so forced.
MARTHA HUNT: Yes.
JASON WU: I can put on
my Oprah hat for you.
The Oprah, the serious--
MARTHA HUNT: It'd be fun
playing Oprah for the day.
JASON WU: Plus, I don't think
you're very interested in that.
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah, social media
takes some getting used to.
JASON WU: Yeah.
MARTHA HUNT: I finally
just got a Facebook.
I've been Snapchatting,
Instagramming.
But now, I feel like
more than ever it's
about creating a brand.
You notice that as well.
You're--
JASON WU: Well, I think
that's very interesting.
I mean, I think
maybe when I met you,
in just such a-- in
five short years,
I feel like modeling
has changed--
MARTHA HUNT: It's changed a lot.
JASON WU: --so much
for you, right?
I feel like--
MARTHA HUNT: Well,
when I first met you,
I had been known more
for my catalog work.
So I was really, really excited
that you took a chance on me
because there were many of
years I was modeling before I
branched into high fashion.
And I had to really persevere
and take risks and management
switch to find an agency
that truly believed in me.
And then one season,
I went out for shows.
And Jason was one of the
first to believe me and put me
in his show.
And since then, it's all
snowballed from there.
And I feel like we
have similar stories
that we believed in ourself.
And we persevered.
JASON WU: Well, I think it's
important with modeling now,
too.
It's like you used to
be-- when I started out,
high fashion was one thing.
You had to be super skinny
and almost no personality,
like robots a little bit.
And I think--
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah, it
was always hard for me.
I always felt like I had to
be so serious all the time.
My agents would tell
me, don't be so bubbly.
And I'm like, well-- and
then people would say, oh,
she looks like a bitch.
I'm like, well, how
am I supposed to act?
There's no right way to do it.
JASON WU: I thought
that when I met you.
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah, see?
There we go.
Here I am trying
to not seem bubbly.
JASON WU: I'm giving
you a great opportunity.
Stop being such a bitch.
You know?
No, but it was really
very interesting
because I've always loved women.
And I love women
with personality
and a point of view.
When I met you,
it was just really
all about the
girls of the moment
were all girls that looked
the same, mostly European,
all speaking English, 16.
MARTHA HUNT: Mhm.
I lived in model apartments
with them throughout the world.
JASON WU: Yeah,
and I just thought,
I want to dress girls
that inspire me.
that are interesting
and I can have a real
conversation with.
And that's what makes
my job interesting
because I envision
everything I do,
every outfit I
design for a girl.
So if something
comes in, I was like,
well-- like today, I gave you
one option to wear, this dress.
No, seriously, because I knew it
was going to look great on her.
We're going to do a red lip.
And we're going to do
the hair back like that,
but very, very specific
because it looks great on her.
Fashion should be curated
to everyone's personality.
MARTHA HUNT: Thank you.
JASON WU: It's not one
size fits all, right?
And I just felt like what
was wrong with the industry
a lot of time was that
these girls were thrust
into these crazy
fashion environments
where they couldn't
possibly have a personality.
MARTHA HUNT: No, of course.
And then people
always wonder why
we don't show our
personality in a casting.
And it's like you
can't even really get
to know somebody within five
seconds of meeting them.
That takes a while after
you've been working together
to build a relationship.
JASON WU: Yeah, but I feel
like you came a super long way
since we met.
MARTHA HUNT: Thank you.
JASON WU: I mean, I think
now it's almost essential.
There's no such thing as
being a commercial model
or a high-fashion model.
In fact, it's all about creating
a brand and being more--
MARTHA HUNT: Well,
it's about treating
the job like a business.
In the beginning, it's funny.
When I first
started modeling, it
was like you're supposed to
take modeling so seriously.
You're not supposed to express
interest in other fields.
But now it's encouraged to
want to do other things,
to start a business, or
act, to do all these things.
And that's because
of social media.
And because they want
you to become a brand,
which I'm actually really
enjoying that part.
Technology is really helping
shape the arc of my career
because social media
is giving me a platform
to show my personality
and hopefully give fans
something to be inspired by.
JASON WU: I don't know if
everyone's saw "Zoolander 2"?
Did anyone see it?
Or else it won't
make-- no one saw it?
OK, it wouldn't make sense.
But it was a funny line
when Penelope Cruz was
like, you know, I used to be
a model, but I have boobs.
And this is why I
couldn't do high fashion.
MARTHA HUNT: I feel like
that line resonated so well
within the fashion industry--
JASON WU: Yeah, I know.
We loved it.
MARTHA HUNT: --because
we know that so well.
It used to be a swimsuit model
couldn't be doing high fashion.
But now you see the
"Sports Illustrated"
models are on the
cover of "Vogue."
And it's all mixed,
which I love that.
I love that we are
all about empowering
different types of women now.
It doesn't have to be this
mannequin stick figure anymore.
It's really exciting.
JASON WU: Speaking with a
bunch of mannequins behind us.
They're all in
this awkward pose.
MARTHA HUNT: Back
to Jason Wu's line.
Cool.
So what about some other
big changes in the industry?
JASON WU: I don't know.
I think it's all changing.
Everyone says faster is better.
I don't really believe that.
I believe that on my phone.
I mean, I'm guilty of that.
If my email doesn't come
through for like five seconds,
I get really upset.
But I think we're
all guilty of that.
And we all are enslaved
to our phones nowadays.
MARTHA HUNT: That's true.
We're all so ADD now.
JASON WU: I know, so ADD.
So I can't really sit still.
I mean, I never could,
but now I really can't.
MARTHA HUNT: Do you
ever imagine just
taking a day not
looking at your phone?
Do you ever do that?
JASON WU: No, I can't.
Like, it's like [GASP].
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah,
that would be horrid.
JASON WU: I can't breathe.
I'm sure everyone
can relate to that.
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah, everyone here
probably can relate to that.
JASON WU: Yeah, but, I mean,
so things are going faster.
There's this conversation
about the clothes
you see on the runway
being available right away,
things like that.
But one thing I would
say, for me, personally,
from my point of view, is that
I don't think everything has
to go the speed of lightning.
I do think there's going to be a
new focus on things of quality,
things that last a long time,
and things that don't go out
of style so quickly.
I never considered
myself a designer
that designed for the season,
the trend of the season.
Of course, sometimes
we hit trends,
as we all do, because
we are inspired
by the world around us.
And so that's how trends emerge.
We don't all meet
in a room and decide
if yellow is in this season.
What's going on in
the world very much
affects what we do as a whole.
MARTHA HUNT: It
happens organically.
JASON WU: Exactly.
But what's become more important
to me now I'm in my 30s
and I've been doing this a while
is that even though technology
is bringing us to the next level
in terms of being very fast,
being aware of everything
that's going on all the time,
being stimulated all the time,
I do think I appreciate things
of quality even more now.
I think about when I'm
buying something for home
or buying something to wear, I
do think about buying something
that I can have for
a long time, not
something I can just throw
away and buy a new one.
And so I do think there
is going to be a renewed
focus on that, especially when
it comes to luxury fashion.
MARTHA HUNT: I've got
more in that direction
with my own style.
I look at really classic pieces.
I used to waste so much
money on trendy things.
And now I just want pieces that
will stand the test of time
and that will always look nice.
JASON WU: And I always think
the world is like a pendulum.
It goes back and forth.
And so if it goes
really fast, it
can go the other
way just as fast.
MARTHA HUNT: Absolutely.
I have a personal question.
Do you think runway
shows will continue?
JASON WU: Yeah.
MARTHA HUNT: There's been a lot
of talk like, oh, it's 2016.
There's got to be a new way to
present a fashion collection.
And I think there
have been attempts.
But what do you think will
be the best way to showcase
new collections in fashion?
JASON WU: I mean, I
think it's different.
For the Jason Wu
collection, I think
we will go to a more
intimate format.
For a while, a few
years ago, it was
essential to be a live
feed, essential to react.
And the truth is
the clothes aren't
really available until
six months later.
So for us, it's
more about curating
a more intimate environment
and cut out all the noise.
For me, it's about that.
MARTHA HUNT: Can
I say, as a model,
we're always annoyed because
when we're walking the show,
all we see are phones like this.
And we're like, is
anybody actually
appreciating the moment?
JASON WU: No,
everyone sees things
to through phones nowadays.
MARTHA HUNT: Front row is
just this the whole time.
JASON WU: I know.
MARTHA HUNT: I'm
like, are you evening
noticing what I'm wearing?
JASON WU: That's
actually quite--
MARTHA HUNT: Or my walk?
JASON WU: One season,
I walked down.
I was like, oh, my god.
People hated the show.
No one clapped.
Because everyone was on
their phone, no one could.
MARTHA HUNT: No one had the
time to even pay attention.
It was, oh wait,
did I catch that?
JASON WU: And then
I read reviews.
Oh, I guess people did
like it in the end.
But you would never know.
So I thought bringing them
back to a smaller, more
intimate environment
where it feels more
like the way they do
it in the '50s where
they have models with cars.
I'm not saying to do that.
But I do think doing
things that are
a little bit more special and
intimate and curated will have
new meaning, especially
in the next couple years--
not just in fashion,
I think in everything.
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah,
I think it's been
very innovative
and natural the way
you've presented the
"Grey" collection.
Because "Grey" for Jason Wu,
you launched that at a dinner
with friends.
And I thought that
that was really
special and unique
that you showed it
in an intimate setting rather
than blasting it online
or in a big print campaign.
JASON WU: I mean, the reason
why I started the collection
"Grey"-- it's my Sister
and Sister collection--
I realized a lot of
my friends were--
they can't afford my clothes.
It retails for $1,500 a pop.
MARTHA HUNT: At
least he's honest.
JASON WU: I'm not even sure I
could afford my own clothes,
if I were a girl.
I mean, that's expensive.
You know?
MARTHA HUNT: It took me a
lot of years to even think
about affording your clothes.
JASON WU: Yeah, it's
frickin' expensive.
So I thought--
MARTHA HUNT: It's art, though.
I mean--
JASON WU: No, I mean--
MARTHA HUNT: It's making art.
JASON WU: I always said,
that's my obsession.
If any of you've been
to the Met recently,
you can see the craftsmanship.
That was a technology-themed
exhibit, but what you see
was a lot of hand work.
So it really goes hand in hand.
That's what I do a lot with
the Jason Wu collection.
I explore techniques, things
inspired from au couture
techniques, things
are done by hand.
It's like creating art.
But for "Grey," I
really wanted to come up
with a collection
that was really
inspired by my friends,
people around me.
Most of my friends
are not in fashion.
I'm still best friends with
my high school friends.
MARTHA HUNT: Oh, really?
JASON WU: Yeah.
MARTHA HUNT: Oh, wow.
That's awesome.
JASON WU: And they're
not in fashion at all.
Or like you, or like
Diane, or people
I'm around with, women that--
MARTHA HUNT: That we can wear.
JASON WU: --care about
clothes, care about style,
but want something a
little more casual,
but also want something
that is not disposable,
but for a reasonable price.
And I think, women, a lot of my
friends are in their early 30s,
late 20s.
And that's when you're
really starting to look
for things to invest in.
So that's what I did "Grey" for,
almost everything under $1,000.
MARTHA HUNT: I love that
they're very comfortable,
but effortless and chic.
I could travel in
this on the plane
and still look nice
at the airport,
but be very comfortable.
It's always an issue for me.
I'm always traveling
all the time.
And I don't want to look sloppy
while I'm at the airport.
JASON WU: And sometimes I was
actually-- a few years ago,
I had to do a project
for "Teen Vogue"
where I had to take a dress and
have to customize it to make
it look like something else.
And I just wanted a really,
really simple dress.
But I only had a $30
budget to buy the dress.
That was the whole project,
that you can elevate something.
MARTHA HUNT: Wow.
JASON WU: So I had a $30 budget.
MARTHA HUNT: Is that what
started "Inspiration" long ago,
or no?
JASON WU: No, no,
it was just-- it's
an interesting example, right?
I was looking for $30 dresses.
But every $30 dress I could
find had tons of stuff on it.
I just really wanted a
white simple something.
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah, not
some crazy paisley print.
JASON WU: Those were all
in the $80 to $100 range.
So it's like
sometimes the simpler
things, things that are more
timeless, are harder to find.
And so I was, like,
oh, maybe there
is some sort of a balance
to buy something that's
affordable, but also has the
appeal of something that's
more classic.
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah, I think
that's really important
for our culture right
now where we are.
When did the development
start for this collection?
JASON WU: I started
about a year ago.
I mean, I think, when launching
a new brand takes a long time.
We had to talk about
branding, thinking about how
to-- the woven label,
what we're going to,
what is the name
of the collection.
We have to go through,
who's the girl,
make tons of inspiration
boards, go back and forth,
lots of fittings,
fittings all the time.
And, yeah, it's
definitely a labor a love.
MARTHA HUNT: How did you
come up with the name "Grey"?
JASON WU: Well, grey
is my favorite color.
I think, my whole
entire apartment's grey.
So my cats are grey,
my curtains grey.
MARTHA HUNT: Your cat's grey.
JASON WU: Everything's grey.
Everything matches.
The point was to
get furniture that
matched the cat so you don't
see the cat hair everywhere.
That was actually how--
MARTHA HUNT: Is there a bigger
meaning with all this grey?
Like it's not black or white?
JASON WU: Yeah, I
mean, I do think that.
I think--
MARTHA HUNT: More subtle?
JASON WU: Yeah, I mean,
I do think especially now
we're living in a world of
this grey zone right now.
And I don't think
it's black and white.
And I think it's good.
For you, when
you're modeling, it
used to be commercial
board and runway board.
But now, there's no such thing.
Everyone's doing everything.
And it's better.
So I do think we're
living in that world
right now where those kind of
labels don't exist as much.
When I was starting
out, also it was
very clear things are
for runway and things
are for commercial purposes.
Well, it's not really
like that anymore.
I think, especially
for me, it was never
about creating clothes that
looked impossible to wear
and then doing something really
dumbed down for the customers.
I think the customers
very much want
to see what's on the runway.
But she also wants to imagine
herself in the clothes.
So she doesn't really want
to carry wheels on the back.
She doesn't really want
to look like a clown.
MARTHA HUNT: So have
you always treated
the street as your runway?
JASON WU: Well, I like reality.
I mean, call me
boring, but I always
thought it was really
nice to be able to see
people wear my clothes.
That's always been the most
interesting thing to me.
I remember when I-- about
eight years ago, when I first
got into Bergdorf Goodman,
I was walking around
on the Upper East Side.
And I saw a girl walk down
the street in a full look.
MARTHA HUNT: Wow, a
full Jason Wu look?
JASON WU: A full Jason Wu look.
And it was the first time
I'd ever seen somebody wear--
MARTHA HUNT: And by
full look, that means?
JASON WU: The top--
MARTHA HUNT: The top.
JASON WU: --and the skirt and
everything that goes with it.
MARTHA HUNT: All Jason Wu.
JASON WU: I was very impressed.
And she was like this
pretty young thing.
She was just walking down.
And I was like, [GASP].
And I just stopped her.
I was like, you look amazing.
And she thought I was so freaky.
MARTHA HUNT: You should
be like, I made that.
JASON WU: I know,
but I was young.
It was like I didn't know
what to do, but, ahh.
MARTHA HUNT: Wow.
That must have been a
surreal moment for you.
JASON WU: Yeah, it was great.
MARTHA HUNT: I always
thought that would
be the fun part for designers,
to actually see people wearing
their clothes on the street.
JASON WU: Well, she spent
money that she could spend
on somebody else on my work.
And she chose to wear it.
It makes her feel great.
And that is the biggest
compliment I could get.
MARTHA HUNT: It's
what it's all about.
JASON WU: And I think
that's very important.
MARTHA HUNT: It's good
that you appreciate that.
JASON WU: Yeah.
MARTHA HUNT: So you've been
using the hashtag #greylavie.
What does that mean to you?
JASON WU: Well, it's because the
collection's about what I like,
my friends.
And I like to entertain.
I prefer to be home with
five, six people than go out
to a restaurant.
MARTHA HUNT: You prefer to be
home rather than going out?
JASON WU: Yeah.
MARTHA HUNT: OK.
JASON WU: I love
hosting at home.
Tonight, I'm doing
a barbecue just
for people that
work at my company.
And I think those
things are really fun.
And, again, I think in this
crazy fast-paced world where
everything goes in warp speed
and things are becoming more
and more impersonal--
MARTHA HUNT: Absolutely.
JASON WU: --I think I'm
starting-- I appreciate
the times where I can
get to know people,
I can get to talk to people.
I mean, how many times have we
been together to big dinners
in those crazy ballrooms in
hotel rooms or those fancy
dinners where the meat is
stale, the fish is over-cooked--
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah, it's true.
JASON WU: --and everyone leaves
before dessert is even served?
MARTHA HUNT: It's so true.
JASON WU: And it's like,
what's the point of all that?
MARTHA HUNT: Like everyone's
going there just for press,
show face.
JASON WU: Yeah, and
it just like I prefer
to have dinner with six people.
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah, I've
always loved that about you.
It's always been about
forming a real connection.
And that's hard to
find in the industry.
It's also hard to find loyalty.
So it's so great that
you've been so loyal to me.
JASON WU: You know what
I'm going to be loyal at?
This cafeteria in this building.
MARTHA HUNT: I know.
JASON WU: That's amazing.
I was hoping--
MARTHA HUNT: It
smelled like Pizza Hut
when I walked on this floor.
JASON WU: I know.
So I heard there's
also a sushi place.
And isn't there a Thai-type
place also, like with pizza?
MARTHA HUNT: No Chinese, though.
JASON WU: So we're going to
go around afterwards and go
to all the cafeteria.
MARTHA HUNT: I'm so
hungry right now.
JASON WU: So jealous.
MARTHA HUNT: So I
think it's about time
that we take some questions
from the audience.
Is that right?
JASON WU: Any questions?
MARTHA HUNT: Questions, anybody?
AUDIENCE: Hey, Jason.
JASON WU: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
My name is Vivian.
I'm an MBA intern
here this summer.
JASON WU: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I was kind of curious.
So over the last
two years, there's
been a greater emergence
of Asian-American voices,
especially in media
and entertainment,
which is not really the case
for when I was growing up.
Given that fashion has been such
a great enabler in promoting
social change and innovation
and new ideas out there,
what do you think your
role is in enabling
more Asian-American, but
also under-represented voices
out there in the media?
JASON WU: I mean,
the truth is-- and we
didn't talk a lot about
that, but I moved to Canada
when I was nine.
And not because I wanted
to because I didn't
want to leave my friends.
I grew up in Taiwan.
And I always liked
to play with dolls.
And my brother was
very macho, played
with Nintendo and trucks.
I played with Barbies.
That's what I preferred.
MARTHA HUNT: I can't see
you with building blocks
and a truck.
JASON WU: No, I preferred
like braid hair.
That was more fun.
And it's funny to talk
about it nowadays.
But in the '80s in Taiwan, it
was really not very acceptable.
People thought it
was very, very weird.
And people thought it was really
quite socially unacceptable.
And I got made fun of a lot.
And even people in
my own family, people
thought it was
really inappropriate.
My parents were
really cool about it.
They just bought me whatever
I wanted to play with.
MARTHA HUNT: Wow,
that's impressive.
JASON WU: So the reason my
mom decided to send myself
and my brother to
Canada was that it
would give us a much more
open-minded environment
to grow.
And growing up in Asia-- I mean,
you mentioned Asian-American--
I think in the
'80s, early '90s, we
were all expected
to go into business,
some sort of a business role.
And creativity wasn't really
appreciated or embraced.
So through amazing
parents and amazing people
I met throughout
my life, I've been
able to succeed doing
exactly what I wanted to do.
MARTHA HUNT: Wow.
Amazing.
JASON WU: So what
I do now, I think
the world is much
different place.
Taiwan is a very
Asia is a different place.
But I do a mentorship program
with a Taiwanese fashion
college.
So I host six kids a season
where they come here.
They get to work with me
for the entire season.
And they have a great resume.
And they get to learn a lot.
And I can help
change the perception
that creative industries
aren't to be taken seriously.
MARTHA HUNT: All changing.
JASON WU: But, again, the
world is a much better place
right now.
It's a much different place.
And I think I'm happy
things have changed.
MARTHA HUNT: Absolutely.
See, it all starts
with the parents.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you for being here today.
JASON WU: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: 10 years ago doesn't
seem like that long ago.
And I'm just curious when
you were first starting out,
who was influential
in your career?
And what advice did they give
you that really stuck with you?
JASON WU: I think my mom
was really very, very, very
influential to me.
I remember when we
were younger, I always
thought I knew everything.
Then she'd smack
me across the head.
She was like, you know nothing.
You know nothing.
And, true.
And that's the best advice
I've been ever given,
is like, OK, actually,
you always go
to an environment,
a new situation,
thinking that you know nothing.
Because the kind
of things you can
learn if you just get rid of
that mental block is amazing.
I learn from the kids that
work for me, the interns.
I learn from my
friends, like you,
what you do on a daily basis,
what's important to you.
You have a foundation, that
you work with the foundation.
And so just learning different
things is really good.
And to not-- don't
be an asshole.
MARTHA HUNT: Be a good person.
JASON WU: Don't think
you know it all.
No, no, like--
MARTHA HUNT: And don't
always believe social media
because everything--
JASON WU: No, just--
MARTHA HUNT: --is deceivingly
perfect all the time.
JASON WU: --be a little
bit more down to earth.
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah, be grounded.
JASON WU: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Jason.
I'm Desmonique.
I work on one of the
advertising sales teams here.
Some of the clients I work
with are in the retail space.
And as you know,
retail is seeing
a decline in foot traffic.
And there's a lot of talk about
rethinking the retail space
for different kinds of
shopping environments
to bring people in.
I'm curious, since
you've probably
shopped around the
world, have you
been in a place recently that
has been indicative of how you
think the shopping experience
should be redefined for today's
consumer in fashion?
And what are your thoughts about
how you would like your clothes
experienced at point of sale?
JASON WU: Well, I think it's
very interesting because this
is where me-- I shop online.
I shop online.
AUDIENCE: We'll tell them that.
JASON WU: No, I
love to shop online.
It's easy.
It's convenient.
But I love going
to stores, but now
for a whole different reason.
I'm not going to go to a
store to buy something just
to buy something.
When I go into a retail space,
I want to have an experience.
And I think what
you're going to see,
like what I said about clothing,
is that the retail experience
has to be special.
The customer experience
And I would say some of the
best stores I've ever been to,
when you go in, you don't
feel like you're in a store.
You're going into the
home or living room.
And I think that's
going to be very, very
important because you're
getting out of your house.
When you want to
go somewhere, you
want to make sure that
it's an experience.
You want to make sure it's
enjoyable and special.
And I think that's what you
can't get on the internet.
That can't be replaced.
I'm opening my first shop
within the Saks Fifth Avenue
this August.
MARTHA HUNT: Oh,
congratulations.
JASON WU: Thank you.
And when people
buy a dress, it's
personalized, engraved their
name in it, things like that,
little gestures like that,
that make it very special.
Like when I do dinners, I
always have place settings
with calligraphy name of every
guest or something like that.
Those little gestures just make
things so much more personal.
Because we don't need to go
anywhere if we don't want to.
MARTHA HUNT: No, we're all busy.
Everyone here is busy.
JASON WU: Yeah, I mean,
between all my apps,
I can get whatever I want in the
city whenever I want at home.
You can.
MARTHA HUNT: It's so true.
JASON WU: I could order ice
cream one day from Postmates,
because [INAUDIBLE].
MARTHA HUNT:
Postmates is my life.
JASON WU: Yeah, it's great.
And so you don't
need to do anything.
So I think retailers have to
think about things differently.
MARTHA HUNT: Also,
going to a store,
you can go with
friends and family.
And that makes it
more of an experience.
JASON WU: It has to
be an experience.
MARTHA HUNT: You want to
shop with friends, something
you don't really do online.
JASON WU: And it
has nothing to do
with price point or any
specific type of things.
But I think when you
go into a store where
it feels warm,
cozy, and welcoming,
and interesting and curated
versus this idea of supermarket
idea, it's different.
MARTHA HUNT: Absolutely.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JASON WU: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm [INAUDIBLE].
I'm an engineering intern.
I had a question-- you
touched upon it a little bit--
but how fashion is moving
towards more of for all women
and not just size zero.
And just it seems like from
an outside perspective,
it's still not really for
a woman of every size,
a woman of every color.
I mean, these
mannequins don't really
have attainable proportions.
And so can you talk
more about just
how some tangible things where
fashion is moving towards being
inclusive of everyone?
JASON WU: Well, I think, yeah,
I mean, yes, these girls are not
the best representations.
I agree.
They were just what's
available for today.
But no, I think it's
interesting, right?
I think standards of beauty
have changed significantly.
And I think we are
seeing a shift of that,
not everyone looks the same.
And as I said,
people are embracing
women of different
personalities,
different ethnic backgrounds,
and different sizes.
I think that's very important.
Whereas I think before, it
was a very closely guarded--
I wouldn't even
just say fashion is,
I would say everything was a
closely guarded-- thing where
things are selected for
you by a small group
of influential people.
But now with social
media, you get
people that are more unlikely
able to be in the public eye
that are in the public eye.
I don't know if that
makes any sense?
MARTHA HUNT: So you're
having to broaden
your sizes for all types.
JASON WU: So you see
a very wide range
of different girls
in fashion magazines
now whereas you wouldn't have
before because these girls are
powerful and people relate
to them on their own.
So the magazines don't
have to feature them now.
They're not selected in a room
by a group of people anymore.
In fact, people are
selecting for the magazines.
And I think that's
a big difference.
I think it's the one thing
that's changing everything.
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah,
and there's plenty
of empowered, curvy
women out there
that are helping shape fashion.
Also, the runways always, to
me, seemed like a fantasy.
And what you see in
fashion campaigns,
it's more like it's artistic.
It's a fantasy.
It's not necessarily
something you
aspire to as your body type.
You have to embrace
where you have.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JASON WU: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Jason.
JASON WU: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming today.
JASON WU: Sure.
AUDIENCE: And Martha, too.
I love your collaboration
with Melissa's Shoes.
I'm actually wearing
one pair today.
JASON WU: I love those.
AUDIENCE: I have three pairs.
I love them.
And I really was excited when
I discovered these shoes,
actually, when I
was in Australia.
I love what Melissa does.
And all her shoes
are recyclable.
And I was wondering if you could
talk a bit about your views
and your thoughts on
sustainability in fashion
and collaborating with
a group like Melissa.
JASON WU: Well, I think
it's a fine balance.
I think it's really not
black and white, right?
I use a lot of natural
materials, a lot of wools.
I was actually just
in Sydney last week
where I went to the wool farms.
I got to shear a sheep.
It was much more fun
in my imagination.
I was like, oh, my god.
They move.
And they're really strong.
And they're aggressive.
MARTHA HUNT: I don't
even see you on a farm.
JASON WU: I don't either.
MARTHA HUNT: How did you
survive on a sheep farm?
JASON WU: First of all,
never go with shoes you like.
Destroyed afterwards.
AUDIENCE: Did your dad give
you some tips before you went?
MARTHA HUNT: There you go.
JASON WU: No, I
mean, I was going,
and I was going to
visit the wool farms.
I was doing a project
with Woolmark.
And so we went to see it.
So you can see that
there's something that's
so beautiful about
natural materials
that I don't think
can ever be replaced.
And so I think there is
very ethical ways to source
these materials.
I think that's very important,
to always know your sources,
whether you are on the vegan
side or not on the vegan side,
there are proper channels
to source all materials.
And same thing with synthetics.
It's about making things
that are like the Melissa
shoes, that can last a long
time, that are produced
in factories that are very,
very well equipped to deal
with plastics and very ethical.
MARTHA HUNT: Ethical, yeah.
JASON WU: Meanwhile,
there's a lot of things
out there that just because
it's vegan, just because it's
sustainable, doesn't
mean it's actually
good for the
environment, either.
I don't know if I'm answering
it correctly, but I think--
AUDIENCE: No, that makes sense.
JASON WU: It's all contextual.
I think we always
have to be very
aware of where our sources are
and what their effects are,
and to make sure that you're
using the best version of that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JASON WU: Thank you.
Did I answer that right?
MARTHA HUNT: Yes.
JASON WU: OK.
AUDIENCE: That's
the correct answer.
JASON WU: I don't know.
I don't know.
MARTHA HUNT: It's all relative.
AUDIENCE: Your perspective.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Jason.
Thank you for coming.
JASON WU: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Likewise, I wanted
to wear something today that's
made by you.
But I have one thing.
It's a leather dress.
And I figure, you
know, for a Thursday,
it might be a little
bit of an overkill here.
JASON WU: That's OK.
MARTHA HUNT: Never, ever.
AUDIENCE: Well, you know.
JASON WU: Look, I
dressed up today.
I'm kidding.
AUDIENCE: Well, that's
actually my question.
You talked about your
interviewer's dress,
hair, makeup even, how
you selected everything.
Can you talk about your
style, what you do?
JASON WU: My style is this.
AUDIENCE: Well, why?
How do you select?
JASON WU: It's black, navy,
grey-- three colors, no hair--
because I really
don't have time.
This is my job.
My job is to make other
people look great.
I'm a much better
behind-the-scene person
than in front.
And so I really have a uniform.
And I'm very uninteresting
in terms of my style.
White sneakers, black sneakers,
black T-shirt, navy T-shirt--
or maybe its a grey one.
Those are very big decisions
I have to make every day.
MARTHA HUNT: Always a
T-shirt, that's true.
JASON WU: Or a
sweater in the winter.
MARTHA HUNT: But I find
this is very common--
JASON WU: I do that.
MARTHA HUNT: --in the industry.
Oftentimes you see
stylists dress down--
sneakers, T-shirts, jeans.
And I think it's
because they treat
their work like their art.
And that's what they're
passionate about, but at home
they don't really care.
JASON WU: I just care about
making her look great.
MARTHA HUNT: Lucky me.
JASON WU: I don't
really care how I look.
I just want to be presentable.
But I keep it really simple.
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah,
simple's good.
JASON WU: It's not about me.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Emily.
I actually have a question
more specified towards Martha.
With your social media, you
have a couple million followers,
which is extremely impressive.
But I've always wondered what
that decision-making process is
like in terms of what
you post professionally
and exposing yourself
to so many followers,
and what you keep
private for yourself.
MARTHA HUNT: It's an
interesting question
because sometimes I do wonder,
should this be private?
But I do notice that the
viewers want to see as much
of your personality as possible.
So I do try to share certain
private moments because that
is relatable and that is me.
Like I try to share my dog or my
boyfriend once in a while or me
cooking because that's
really who I am.
And it looks like I'm made up in
all these fabulous destinations
all the time, but
people should take it
all with a grain of salt
because it is curated.
And Instagram is
like the final image.
That's how you want to
present yourself to the world.
But you don't see
a lot of what's
really going on all the time.
And I'm not going to
bash a job if it's not
going well on Instagram.
So you're just going to
see me looking great.
But I do think it is a little
bit deceiving that things
look so great all the time.
I mean, I'm very appreciative
of my life and all that.
But there's this
thing in culture
now where I feel like
everyone's feeling
this fear of missing out.
And I just want to remind
people that it's all a fantasy.
JASON WU: Models eat, too.
We're going to have pizza later.
MARTHA HUNT: Yes, and
I also try to show
that I work out a lot
because I think it's
important to motivate people.
That helps people get
inspired to get to the gym.
And it takes a lot of work
to maintain my figure.
I'm not trying to act like,
oh, I eat whatever I want.
And I'm tall and
thin and all that.
I definitely work
out and work for it.
AUDIENCE: I think
that's been more
of a trend, though,
of people-- a lot
of models being more
open about that and about
how much work it takes
to eat healthfully
to-- especially while
traveling and your lifestyle
is so demanding.
And that's hard
for someone going
to work at the same
job every single
day and workplace let alone
traveling all over the world
and not having any of
your comforts around.
MARTHA HUNT:
Understandably, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it's nice that
there's so much exposure there.
JASON WU: I mean, you and Karlie
inspire me to go work out.
MARTHA HUNT: Oh, thank you.
JASON WU: You guys are
always going to work out.
I finally got my ass out
to the gym this year.
MARTHA HUNT: Always, yeah.
JASON WU: Everything's wrong.
MARTHA HUNT: But there's also
a tremendous amount of pressure
to post.
Sometimes I feel
like, oh, I feel
like I'm so annoying putting
all this content out there.
But we're also getting
pressure from our agencies.
We need more content.
Show your personality,
because it's
designers like Jason
who are casting
girls that have a following.
It's become such a key role
in our industry for the model.
JASON WU: Yeah, so important.
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah,
it's so important.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARTHA HUNT: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question about
dressing celebrities.
You talked a little bit about
seeing the person walking down
the street on the
Upper East Side.
And that gave you joy.
But then how do
you reconcile when
we talk about awards seasons and
all these different big events,
and you have very high profile
people wearing your clothes.
What does that feel like?
Is that the same level?
Is that the same level of joy?
Or is that not as
important to you anymore?
Because I think you've dressed
First Ladies and all of that.
Is there an aspirational
piece, like I
want to dress this
person, but it's also
interesting to see normal
people wearing my clothes?
How does that feel?
JASON WU: I think it's both.
I mean, I think it's different.
I love seeing people wear
my clothes in general.
It's two very different
things, right?
I love seeing-- I go
to stores all the time.
I interact with my customers.
I dress them.
And I suggest.
I'm very blunt.
So if something doesn't look
good on her, I would just say,
don't buy it.
I'm very-- I love that
process of working with people
and making them feel
great and look amazing.
And seeing my work on them
makes me feel very good.
Award season is different.
For me, from I would say a
small brand point of view,
a lot of what red carpet has
become is product placement.
And a lot of actors
are endorsing brands.
And for me, for my own
brand, almost, I would say,
all the actresses
and people I dress
are people I have a
relationship with.
So to me, it becomes about
me helping them accomplish
something at a moment
that's important to them,
me making them look the best.
MARTHA HUNT: Very exciting.
JASON WU: And so it's a little
bit more personal for me.
And it makes me feel very
proud if a friend of mine
wins something and
she's wearing my design.
I feel like part of the success.
So my goal has always been
more a personal one, I guess.
So, yeah, I still get a rush
seeing something very public
happen, something I'm very
proud of my friend for doing,
and that I can be a part of that
through making her look great.
MARTHA HUNT: Could you
share an example of a friend
that you were really
excited that you got
to dress in an exciting moment?
JASON WU: I mean,
Kerry Washington,
she's been my friend for
like-- she's actually
one of the first
actresses to ever wear me.
So I met her about
nine years ago.
MARTHA HUNT: She's stunning.
JASON WU: A couple years ago,
she was going to the Oscars.
And she's pregnant
with her first baby.
It was really her moment.
She was presenting,
and people were just
throwing everything at her.
And this is very rare.
Three months before the Oscars,
she asked me to make her dress.
And she never changed her mind.
That sounds maybe not
like so much right
now, but, honestly, actresses
get so much given to them,
that they can change
their mind at any moment
in the last minute.
And she did that.
And it was really a
very special moment.
AUDIENCE: What about
dressing the First Lady?
How's that like?
JASON WU: Amazing.
I mean, to be able to-- for me,
as an Asian-American Canadian
person, to be an immigrant,
to be the first Asian person
to dress the first
African-American First Lady is
super significant to me.
I never imagined that
that's something I
would be able to be a part of.
I wanted it to be in "Vogue."
But after that
experience, I started
thinking so much
bigger, like thinking
about how there's so much--
MARTHA HUNT: How many
more boxes can you tick?
JASON WU: I mean, though,
it just humbled me a lot.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Hey.
Thanks so much for being here.
This is great.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I had a question
around the price point.
You mentioned earlier
that even sometimes you
think you can't afford
your own clothes, right?
And I understand completely that
good quality, craftsmanship,
and materials, and design,
et cetera, in any field--
whether that's clothing or
food or anything-- costs a lot
of money.
Have you ever
thought about trying
to adapt your
lines in the future
to be more accessible from
a price point perspective?
JASON WU: Well, I
just launched "Grey,"
which is the collection
that is much more accessible
and a price point between $150
to $800 for an outerwear piece,
for example.
So that's definitely a
different price range for me.
But it's still
pricey, but I think
it's also made with
an understanding
that it's clothes you
can keep for a long time.
It's not throw-away.
MARTHA HUNT: Yeah,
they're classic pieces.
They're classic
investment pieces.
JASON WU: They give you
fashion, but there's still
a timelessness.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
curious on that.
What needs to be
changed to actually
bring the price point down?
What are the elements
that actually--
JASON WU: Well, lot
of different things.
I think, look, it's also just
very different kind of clothes
for me.
Now, look, if you
see these pieces,
these are from collection.
These are from "Grey."
These are much more day.
They're much easier to
wear, casual shapes.
Here, this is very expensive
because it's a down jacket made
with this feather ball fabric.
And it's hand-embroidered over
1,000 hours, little feathers
encrusted on with beads.
If you look at the craftsmanship
of that, that's the difference.
I'm not going to be
able to bring that
for a different price point.
But that's my obsession, the
art of creating something
so painstakingly made that it's
just sometimes beyond reason.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Jason.
My question is actually very
related to the last one.
So there's a certain warmth
to handmade clothing,
whereas a lot of
times technology
gets the stigma of
being very cold.
What techniques did you
use in your collection
to make the clothes still
very special and warm?
JASON WU: I mean, everything
I make is made by hand.
I'm a true believer in that.
I'm not very good at
drawing on the computer.
I'm much better drawing by hand.
So I'm a very
hand-oriented person.
I do think that's something
that will probably never
change for me.
But I mean, definitely to
use technology in fashion
doesn't mean take away the hand.
You can laser cut a fabric.
You can treat it with some
sort of interesting coating
to either change the appearance
or texture of the fabric
or the function of the fabric.
Those are things that could be
very beneficial through using
technology.
But the truth is,
there is still really
no such thing as
machine-made fashion.
Even the T-shirt I'm wearing
or something that you think
is machine made, a
pair of hands still
has to put it
through the machine.
It doesn't really exist.
There's no such thing as a
machine made fashion really,
not yet.
AUDIENCE: Until robots
are putting clothes
through the machine.
JASON WU: Yeah, no, I mean,
something as simple as this,
it's still made by
a pair of hands.
MARTHA HUNT: That's true.
That's a good point.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
JASON WU: Thank you.
MARTHA HUNT: Thank you.
Well, I think that's all
we have time for today.
JASON WU: Thank
you for having us.
MARTHA HUNT: Thank you
guys so much for having us.
It was such an honor.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]